bonsoir il y en soit chaque soir pendant
trois semaines vous allez nous faire
vivre cette campagne des municipales oui
elle accélère cette campagne tous les
soirs nous allons vous la faire vivre à
la fois avec des gros plan sur 15 villes
de la région mais aussi en vous
expliquant comment se passe ce scrutin
en détaillant 15 mots de ces élections
puis on ira voir ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux il s'y passe beaucoup de
choses c'est devenu un espace très
important pour ces élections municipales
et alors on va vous pour commencer on va
en bresse à louhans dans une ville
longtemps dirigé par la droite qui a
basculé à gauche en 2008 mais le
contexte est particulier avec un
changement de maire au cours du dernier
mandat rémi chaintron est parti diriger
le conseil général et une fusion de deux
communes loin et châteaurenaud qui
pourrait peser sur le scrutin avec
quatre listes en présence que sont allés
rencontrer michel gillot et gabrielle
talon monique bonin est devenu maire de
loin en juin 2012 lorsque rémi chaintron
a quitté ce fauteuil pour présider le
conseil général lui même succédant à
arnaud montebourg entrée au gouvernement
aujourd'hui elle conduit la liste ps
pour les municipales est ce un
leadership provisoire
saint trond est actuellement président
du conseil général et c'est une fonction
qui lui va très bien
je ne pense pas que il serait intéressé
par
un retour en tant que maire de louhans
châteaurenaud
mais de toute façon nous avons un
faisons un travail d' équipe
donc si un jour on devait revoir
l'attribution des sièges
ça ne poserait pas de problème ni aux
uns ni aux autres
pour l'heure en tout cas monique bonin
fait campagne et l'a visiblement une
cible privilégiée
la personne qui veut le pouvoir
elle a pas beaucoup de projets mais elle
veut elle veut être à la tête de la
ville monique bonneaud parle ainsi de
marie françoise muller elle est à la
tête d'une liste dite citoyenne ce qu'il
a rempli deux le fait de faire ce projet
sans avoir à d'europe de comptes à
rendre à qui que ce soit politiquement
et bien je me sens légère et marie
françoise muller mettre une sourdine à
son engagement à gauche elle fit
notamment conseillère régionale elle fut
aussi maire délégué de châteaurenaud
aujourd'hui cette commune associée a
disparu absorbé par loin madame bühler
s'est battu contre la décision
préfectorale mais cet épisode dit elle
n'explique pas sa candidature
ma démarche actuellement elle n'est pas
dans un esprit de revanche
la page est tournée pour moi et j'ai des
projets même pour le quartier de
château-regnault puisque c'est un
quartier maintenant mais je trouve que
c'est dommage d'avoir donné un coup de
canif dans notre démocratie et dans le
rapport à nos concitoyens
le marché de loin est moins florissant
fils n'a été et dynamiser le
développement économique et touristique
figurent au programme de tous les
candidats
frédéric bouchet agents immobiliers se
présente comme un homme de droite bien
implantée dans sa ville moi je sors du
milieu associatif
donc je suis dans le milieu associatif
sportif culturel
économique voilà il ya un moment donné
bon on a envie d'aller au delà et puis
rendre à louhans châteaurenaud tout le
bien qu'ils m'ont donnée donc c'est du
ce voit là c'est aussi une démarche
personnelle et une envie de faire donc
je me présente c'est faciale moi je suis
candidat à la liste donc louhans
châteaurenaud bleu marine
sébastien loin dit bleu marine et pas
front national il n'est pas le seul à
parler de sécurité mais on sent là un
terrain de prédilection nous avons
commencé de proposer donc l'installation
de vidéo protection pour assurer
vraiment la sécurité de tous nos
concitoyens de nos électeurs des
habitants car on a une recrudescence de
la petite délinquance de vols de
braquage donc qui devient quand même de
plus en plus important sur nouveau en
dehors des étiquettes des personnes et
des programmes la disparition de la
commune associée de châteaurenaud
aura-t-elle un impact sur l'élection
louhannaise c'est la grande inconnue de
ce scrutin
nous allons donc prendre le temps aussi
dans cette page spéciale d'expliquer de
détailler les mots qui font cette
actualité politique et pour ce premier
journal de campagne c'est le mot
campagne justement campagne nom féminin
qui en langage militaire désigne un
ensemble d'opérations menées sur un
terrain d'eternit en matière d'élection
c'est un peu comme à la guerre
une campagne et efficace que si l'on est
bien armé la question donc d'y aller la
fleur au fusil
d'autant plus que le terrain d'action
est particulièrement miné de règles
précises pour les municipales la
bataille électorale officielle a
commencé le 1er mars à partir de cette
date
taïaut taïaut tous à cheval la bagarre a
pu commencer tracts réunions publiques
médias nés tous les coups ne sont pas
permis
interdit de coller ses affiches
n'importe où un seul porte drapeau le
célèbre
panneau électoral les médias ces héros
des temps modernes doivent quant à eux
veiller à des temps de parole équitable
pour tous les candidats et leurs
soutiens interdit d'essayer de rameuter
la cavalerie adverse en distribuant des
tracts la veille et le jour du scrutin
pendant deux jours ci drapeau côté
numéraire interdit de faire fondre
l'argenterie ou de vendre les marques du
musée municipal les candidats dans les
communes de plus de 9000 habitants pour
l'obligation d'avoir un compte de
campagne
mais quel que soit celui qui aura gagné
les clés de la ville au final c'est le
même régime il faudra laisser la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne de financement politique
si si ça existe vérifiez que recettes et
dépenses sont bien en règle et vous le
disais en partent en campagne à fleurs
au fi l actualité de la campagne et lyon
c'est aussi à nevers et à sang oui vous
vous souvenez cas nevers on avait évoqué
les longues tractations entre l'ump eut
dit eh bien c'est sûr elles ont échoué
puisque après l'ump de philippe cordier
la semaine dernière c'est lui des hymnes
et par guillaume maillard qui a présenté
sa liste ce week end et puis en marge du
débat agité que nous avons organisée à
100 c'est que vous avez peut-être suivi
on a appris qu europe ecologie les verts
de sens a décidé de s'associer avec le
maire sortant divers gauche michel
fourré ce débat justement a fait parler
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux que
nous suivrons attentivement pour vous
pendant cette campagne
en commençant d'abord par un tweet
politique avec le candidat socialiste
pascale simon plutôt content de lui
après le débat de sens puisque il
s'attribue la victoire carrément
victoire dans le débat en tout cas avant
la fameuse photo de groupe des stars de
la cérémonie des oscars twittait à plus
de 2 millions d'exemplaires
il y avait déjà eu ce qu'on appelle un
selphy pendant notre débat une équipe de
campagne qui se photographier c'était
celle de francine weecksteen et puis
pour ce soir l'oscar du tweet politico
animalier est attribuée à françois
boucher candidat l'ump de migennes dans
l'yonne qui fait remarquer qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant de listes dans sa ville
des listes qu'il qualifie de crocodiles
et pour être bien sûr qu'on a compris il
rajoute une photo de crocodiles on ne
sait pas si elle a été prise sur les
rives de l'yonne ou de l'armançon merci
vous nous direz ça demain j'ajoute les
liens qu'on peut retrouver toutes les
infos relatives à la campagne et le
dessous de la vie politique sur le blog
que vous animez avec eric sicaud au blog
qui s'appelle politique en bourgogne
merci lilian à demain